a
[Música]
aquí comienza a ellos hoy de france 24
el pasado 10 de mayo se radicó ante el
congreso de colombia del proyecto de ley
inconvertible es que busca y legalizar
las llamadas terapias de conversión en
el país también conocidas como eco ciega
la iniciativa tiene como fin el respeto
a las orientaciones sexuales de las
personas a gays lesbianas y demás
integrantes de la comunidad del eje vete
y comas y es que para sus impulsores
intentar cambiar o reprimir la
orientación sexual y la identidad de
género es una violación a los derechos
humanos este proyecto está respaldado
por una investigación del portal
periodístico volcánicas aquí algunos
testimonios anónimos leídos por
voluntarios tuve un año viendo cómo
oraban por mí y me liberaba de ser gay
la voz se corrió ahí y entonces todo el
mundo oraba por mí me miraban como si
tuviera una enfermedad terrible y me
tuvieran que sanar vas a tener terapias
de electrochoques que van a mostrar
fotos de hombres desnudos y te van a dar
choques hasta que tu cuerpo acepte que
es
tuve muchas ganas de matarme no lo
concreté pero hice una carta de suicidio
que escribí en modo automático al final
decía perdón por todo pero nunca pude
dejar de ser gay me hicieron una especie
de exorcismo de iniciación antes de
entrar a la iglesia me taparon la cara
hasta que me llevaron hasta el púlpito
en la parte de adelante y empezaron a
hacer una serie de oraciones que eran
parte del exorcismo me echaban una
especie de cenizas y me decían que mi
cuerpo y mi espíritu estaba marcado y
que había que limpiar tengo dos hermanos
que me castigaban por ser y me acosaban
y me chabán gargajos en la boca me
dijeron supuestamente que eran
acupuntura luego me di cuenta que eran
hormonas para volverme hombre me salió
hasta bigote me hicieron sentir muy
culpable porque me decían que cada vez
que yo sentía atracción hacia una mujer
era porque tenía un espíritu adentro y
que esto era una enfermedad mental tú
sabes que ellos están dispuestos a
internarse en sitios si tú no aceptas
hacer esta terapia conmigo el pastor
intentaba empujar en el piso como lo
hacía en su servicio y yo no me deje me
decía que el demonio actuaba por mí
porque no hay nada que curar porque
probamos las mal llamadas terapias de
conversión en colombia vamos a conversar
sobre este tema y para eso están en
ellas hoy andrés forero que es gerente
de campañas de all out el movimiento
global por los derechos lgtb
que impulsa el proyecto ante el congreso
colombiano y dante haro belmonte
directora de la fundación grupo de
acción y apoyo a personas trans gracias
por estar con nosotros y quisiera
comenzar a andrés con ustedes para que
hablemos lo primero en qué consiste
proyecto para ilegalizar estas llamadas
terapias de conversión
angela muchísimas gracias por la
invitación al programa
básicamente el proyecto y convertibles
busca que las mal llamadas terapias de
conversión se erradique en nuestro país
se radiquen en colombia y para lograr
eso básicamente prohíbe que cualquier
persona natural o jurídica practique
este tipo de terapias eco 7 como se les
conoce oficialmente y además también la
reconoce como una forma de tortura lo
cual implica que serían sancionadas como
tal en nuestro país el proyecto propone
que quien practique con ciega en
colombia sea
penalizado justamente por practicar una
forma de tortura y además también obliga
que las personas que acampar te de los
sectores de salud profesionales de la
salud reciban orientación sobre temas
del egb estos son los principales puntos
de este proyecto de ley bueno y esto es
muy importante porque además no hay una
educación que sea humanizada o una
atención clínica que sea humanizada y
con un enfoque de género y aquí le
quiero preguntar a dan ser diverso no
equivale a padecer una enfermedad mental
ni a un problema espiritual esto quedó
descartado por la organización mundial
de la salud hace ya años entonces como
se combate una terapia de conversión
cuáles son los argumentos para educar a
la gente que todavía sigue pensando
erróneamente que hay algo mal con las
personas diversos
yo creo que lo principal y lo que hemos
dicho también desde las mismas
organizaciones sociales es que
necesitamos más información que hable de
nuestras orientaciones sexuales nuestras
identidades de género no desde una parte
digamos desconociendo que es algo que no
podemos cambiar realmente que nuestras
orientaciones sexuales sin hacer
ciencias de géneros pues están bien y
para eso necesitamos es que no solamente
las organizaciones generemos este
conocimiento sino que también desde el
estado desde los centros de salud
incluso desde las mismas comunidades
religiosas de vernos como si fuéramos
personas enfermas o que tenemos algo que
debe ser cambiado corregido bueno andrés
el sustento de este trabajo de este
proyecto que ustedes intentan adelantar
en colombia tiene que ver también con
investigaciones realizadas por la
publicación 9 feminista colombiana
volcánica si entonces quisiera
preguntarle que han encontrado ustedes
en este trabajo en conjunto sobre las
terapias hoy sobre por ejemplo si hay
principalmente un origen religioso en la
realización de estas actividades
claro que si angela bueno todas estas
iniciativas comenzaron básicamente
porque hace aproximadamente un año desde
la organización del auto nos estábamos
preguntando que pasaban con las terapias
de conversión en colombia como sucedían
y al no encontrar información decidimos
salir a buscar testimonios de personas
que quisieran dar su voz y encontramos
20 testimonios entre ellos los de edad y
estos testimonios serán entregados de la
revista volcánicas para que hiciera una
investigación periodística que pudieran
desenmascarar por así decirlo las mal
llamadas terapias de conversión en
nuestro país esta investigación
justamente puso en evidencia algo que ya
la onu algo que ya organizaciones como
ilga y la asociación americana de
psicólogos había dicho las terapias de
conversión son igualadas a forma de
tortura tienen graves consecuencias
físicas y psicológicas en las personas
del g20 y deben ser prohibidas entonces
lo que encontramos en los testimonios
básicamente porque muchas de estas
personas fueron llevadas organizaciones
religiosas agrupaciones e incluso
consultorios psicológicos en donde les
decían que necesitaban ser curadas y
utilizaban prácticas violentas que van
desde exorcismos pasando incluso por
agresiones físicas incluso abuso sexual
justamente para corregir lo que es
incurable porque las personas se les
eviten no necesitamos cura está estos
esfuerzos fueron acompañados justamente
con una campaña que lanzamos desde la
organización online que recaudó más de
48 mil firmas de personas que exigían
que el gobierno colombiano radicar un
proyecto de ley para prohibir estar mal
de estas más de más terapias gracias a
andrés
para pasar otra vez escondan y quisiera
que habláramos un poco más de feminismo
porque es importante que el enfoque de
género y que los derechos humanos
cobijen las iniciativas por este respeto
a la diversidad y además por proteger a
los ciudadanos sin importar cuál sea su
expresión de género o su sexualidad y
pues entre otras cosas está dentro de
esta población una parte muy importante
que son aquellas personas que se
perciben como mujeres
i
o un campo super inexplorado también de
parte del estado que es poder garantizar
realmente los derechos humanos de las
mujeres en colombia de las personas de
los actores sociales el eje de digamos
han habido unos avances como la política
pública el gerente pero pues es una
política pública que le falta muchísimo
también para poder garantizar realmente
nuestras vidas y nuestra existencia y
allí vamos el papel de un estado súper
fundamental porque queremos dejar de ser
vistes como un sector social
históricamente minorizado y empezar a
vernos como parte activa en la sociedad
para eso necesitamos claramente que pues
no solamente colombia yo creo que
también a nivel latinoamericano se
reconozca los derechos de todas las
personas parte de este reconocimiento de
derechos es poner por ejemplo este
proyecto de ley de marchena terminales y
real para que estas terapias y estos
procesos de conversión pues no sigan
ocurriendo en el país
andrés donde suceden las terapias de
conversión a quien es una de las
personas que son principales víctimas de
estas mal llamadas terapias y cómo se
pueden detectar cuáles son esos signos
de alerta que debemos tener en cuenta
las familias para proteger a nuestras
personas diversas bueno es una excelente
pregunta porque justamente lo que
encontramos en el reportaje volcánicas
es que estas terapias ustedes de maneras
muy diversas y existen de muchísimas
formas no hay solamente una única manera
la que pasa sino que pueden suceder como
te dije antes en iglesias en consultor y
psicológicos en agrupaciones religiosas
entonces los signos de alerta
principalmente es cuando una persona
elige dt le cuenta a su familia que es
gay sale del closet por ejemplo y la
familia en lugar de buscar educación
afirmativa y celebrarlo y respetarle su
identidad sexual busca reprimir la y
decir tengo que tengo que llevar tetera
que tenemos que buscar algún tipo de
tratamiento que te traten entonces
justamente el primer signo alerta es
este rechazo hacia
la orientación sexual o la identidad de
género a una persona que no pertenezca
al aziz género o la heterosexual una vez
sucede ese rechazo y las familias tienen
esta idea de que ser el eje vete es algo
que necesita cura pues ahí es donde se
empieza a ir por el camino que
justamente estamos buscando evitar que
es un camino de rechazo y camino de odio
el el punto clave justamente es que
cuando una persona cuenta que es el eje
vete que sea respetada y sea firmada
inmediatamente por su familia y por
todas las personas en sus círculos
sociales cercanos sus colegios sus
comunidades locales su misma sucesión
municipalidades entonces es ahí donde
este proyecto de ley y donde la política
pública la gente en colombia deberían de
actuar bueno andrés cuando estábamos
organizando este programa fuera del aire
hablamos también de la campaña que
ustedes adelantan en general que va más
allá de este proyecto de ley yo quisiera
por favor que nos hiciera un poco la
mención de lo que esto significa y en
qué consiste en cuanto a una restitución
de derechos para la comunidad diversa
claro que si angela esto
hace poco hace nada más una semana
cuando se presentó el proyecto de ley
lanzamos una nueva campaña que busca
justamente la aprobación de este
proyecto de ley o la otra es una
organización que se dedica a reunir a
miles de voces en pro de una sola causa
y la campaña que lanzamos en el pasado
para presionar por la presentación de
este proyecto de ley para un éxito más
de 48.000 personas se sumaron a ella y
ahora estamos lanzando una nueva campaña
que está buscando la aprobación
definitiva de este proyecto de ley ahora
en colombia nos enfrentamos a un periodo
complejo tenemos elecciones
presidenciales vamos a tener un nuevo
gabinete en el congreso y lo que
buscamos con esta campaña es lograr que
este proyecto de ley no se hunda sino
que por el contrario se apruebe en su
mayor brevedad le generó también a que
firmen la petición tenemos actualmente
más de 12 mil firmas y estamos siguiendo
contando pues es una lucha que
seguramente va a ser larga y pues que
nosotros vamos a estar aquí para
registrar a cada paso y ya para ir
cerrando dane usted es la directora de
la fundación grupo de acción y apoyo a
personas trans y en ese sentido pues la
discriminación no es un tema nuevo ni en
colombia ni en américa latina' que debe
hacer una persona que ha sufrido
violencia por su ex de género cómo puede
usted o cómo pueden las organizaciones
ayudar a dónde deben acudir
yo creo que principalmente
reconocer que no estamos solos no
solamente las personas que han sido
víctimas de violencia tiene por ejemplo
a las comisión sobrevivientes de estas
violencias y además terapias de
conversión y acercarse a la organización
social y recibir acompañamiento el gat
siempre tiene las puertas abiertas para
aquellas familias de personas trans para
aquellas personas trans infancias trans
que busquen conocimiento ayuda que
realmente a pierde sus identidades que
les reconozca sus derechos y la
invitación es siempre pues a querernos
ya construir desde el amor yo siento que
hay algo fundamental que ha transformado
yo creo que la vida de muchas familias y
personas que se han acercado a la
fundación y es justamente construir
entes de un reconocimiento
amoroso y cariñoso porque eso permite
que podamos como personas puede
desarrollarse hace parte de esta
construcción colectiva que llamamos
sociedad invitación siempre es abierta a
que reconozcan que hacemos parte
y toda esta estructura además de todo
permite que nuestros derechos sean
efectivos
pues bien muchísimas gracias son
entonces andrés forero gerente de
campañas de all out el movimiento global
por los derechos lgtb de más y dane haro
belmonte directora de la fundación el
grupo de acciones y apoyo a personas de
trans gracias por estar con nosotros
hagamos
y a todos nuestros televidentes
continúen en france24 nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy y no hay nada
que curar
[Música]